i'm here to do today is to tell you
about the exciting world of deep
learning and the role of data in it
specifically i'm going to talk about a
problem with data and deep learning and
basically practical solutions to solve
that problem
i will attempt to leave two to five
minutes at the end for questions and i
will try to make the sort of ratio of
information to shilling about 90 to 10
um so let me know if you have any
feedback but as a quick intro for me i'm
peter
uh i'm the co-founder ceo at a company
called aquarium and uh i'll go into that
later in the 10 or the shilling part but
you know apart from that i worked on
deep learning systems for a number of
years at a company called cruise that
was building self-driving car stuff
before that i worked on this framework
called cafe at berkeley which was you
know kind of the original
deep learning framework before
tensorflow and pytorch came on the scene
but
the thing i'm here to talk to you about
today is this idea that has been getting
a lot of credits in you know recent
years you know andre karpovi and you
know andrea go up and they talk about
how you know there's this idea of data
centric ml or that like you know people
should really focus on working on the
data to get improvement to their machine
learning models and you know most
practitioners i think would agree that
this is the case so if you want to like
work on your data you know working on
your data typically gets you a lot
higher roi in terms of improving your
machine learning model performance at
the end of the day compared to you know
working on other stuff like hyper
parameter tuning
so that's a cool idea that's awesome um
problem is it's all like you know high
level makes a lot of sense yeah that
sounds great but what do i actually do
and so some part of this is okay well
let's try and understand the motivation
of why this is important and then we can
talk about like practical tips for you
to apply this to your own setup or
workflow
so i think number one the reason why we
talk about this is because if you want
to improve a machine learning model then
you have you know basically two options
in regular software engineering you have
the code and as in machine learning you
also have code and you can make
improvements to that in terms of
changing your model architecture
changing the way that your model is
trained in terms of the parameters
things like that but you also have this
new thing that is not present in most
software engineering which is the idea
of data which is what makes machine
learning machine learning you know you
train this model code on the data you
produce this model that then does some
stuff that you want
so when you want to improve your ml
system you want to improve both of these
as fast as you can and as frequently as
you can and then you get better models
that you can then ship into production
um and so
now comes the part where you know
obviously we've been doing machine
learning for quite a number of decades
you know what's so different about this
whole data center ml thing now and the
reason why is because there's been this
shift towards working on
deep learning as opposed to what
previously was the big thing which was
structured machine learning so if you
look at you know google facebook a lot
of companies in the early 2000s to 2010s
you know they were focusing on tasks
like forecasting recommendation ag
targeting focusing on data types that
you can store in a sql database and you
know the sort of thing that you look at
in that sort of domain is that you have
data that comes to you for free because
a lot of the time you have millions of
users on your site that are just like
clicking around and you know your task
in machine learning is you want to be
able to predict what they're going to do
better so that you can you know sell
them ads or like you know sell them
things on your ecommerce site so you
know the algorithms were more things
that were like traditional like you know
non-deep learning algorithms like
logistic regression and the sort of
focus of the work the the people who get
paid the most
were the data scientists because you
know since the data came for free you
just need to kind of crank through the
data more frequently you got to retrain
the model you know every week every day
you gotta like you know scale it to you
know millions billions of data points
but then most of the improvement to the
models
came from feature engineering on the
structured data or like you know doing
stuff on like experimentation with the
models like you know sparse models or
you know trying new algorithms or ways
of training it or something like that
but with deep learning
you have a different paradigm
now you deal with uh unstructured data
like imagery like audio which has its
own set of challenges to handle
you're using deep learning models to
handle this data
and then now you have this sort of
economic shift which is that the data
does not come for free you know now you
actually have to go and pay companies
like scale or label box or maybe you
build your own system where you get a
bunch of people offshore to go drop
boxes on this is a car this is a person
this is what the person was saying in
the audio clip that sort of thing
so now as a result like you know because
the models are pretty good because you
can get a lot of pre-trained deep neural
nets you know just off the shelf from
open source like you know they're pretty
good you can't really do that much to
improve on what facebook ai research or
google brain has done so there's not
much you can do there the data pipelines
you know you still need to scale it of
course so there's going to be tools that
help you with that but now you have this
limitation which is since you don't have
all the data coming to you for free you
have this decision which is like okay
well i collect a lot of data but i can't
label all of it and when i do label it
you know is it
good
or is it bad and also what should i
spend my limited dollars on labeling in
order to get the most impact to improve
your model so now everyone's talking
about what do we need to do to work on
the data because it's a new sort of
problem that was created by a new
paradigm of doing machine learning
so
now we go from like you know the high
level okay well why do we care about
this to okay what do we do
and you know if you kind of break it
down into steps i want to make my data
better what do i need to do well you
have kind of like a feedback loop right
you have like the sort of iteration
cycle just like you have with like
software engineering one what is the
problem you know is it the problem with
your data is it a problem with your
model you know like what are the
problems
two is like
why are they happening you know is it a
problem where
you know the data is being mislabeled is
a problem where like it's inconsistent
is the problem where you don't have
enough of something that's hard
and then you got to go take actions to
fix the data you know edit things modify
things add stuff remove stuff
and then as you change your data retrain
your model you got to make sure that the
model is getting better the problems are
getting fixed and then cool get it on in
production and then you repeat this
again and again and again until you have
a much better model in production so
it's kind of like agile software
development but with machine learning
so
this goes into okay well like what are
the type of problems you have and what
do you do to solve them
so in unstructured data you have you
know various different types of what i
would call data problems
so the sort of you know i phrase it as
like maslow's hierarchy of ml so at the
base of it you want to have data that
itself is good like you know your images
or your audio have to be like not
malformed so if you see for example you
know this is very common with some
images where the hardware can screw up
and produce something that's distorted
this is like you know
the stuff in my sql database is you know
garbled or something by some process
that happened ahead of it so you should
probably just fix that that's like data
cleanliness
on top of that though you have this
operational process which is we need to
get people to label data to tell the
model what to do and because you have
people labeling this data the people
make mistakes so this is idea of
labeling errors or inconsistencies or
ambiguities so this is an example from
when andrew ings talks where you have
these defects in like a sheet of metal
well one labeler says i'm going to draw
a box around each of the little dots and
then the other labeler says i'm going to
draw a box around all of them
and you know both are kind of like
technically correct but since they're
inconsistent it confuses the model the
model screws up and then like you know
doesn't do what you want
and then beyond that you have higher
level problems like okay well like you
know i don't have enough examples of a
certain rare case
or for example you have something that
is happening in production
that isn't happening in the set that
your model is trading on so model
doesn't know what to do and it can't
handle it so you have to be able to
diagnose all these problems and
understand the resolutions you have to
take to fix them
so this gets into the point of how do i
find the problems and you know all those
steps that i highlighted in the feedback
loop they have their own sort of
problems and how do you need to like you
know set up a workflow that solves them
efficiently so i'm just going to talk
about just problem discovery how do you
even know where the problems are because
likely you have a data set that you're
training your model on that is like
millions of examples but
probably only a few of them
are actually like bad you know only a
few of them have bad labels maybe only a
few of them have you know like you know
difficult scenarios that your model
struggles with so one way to do this is
that you have an operational process and
you just spend a lot of money on it so
if i want to find all the label errors
in my data set well one thing i can do
is i can just pay three different people
to go look through every point in my
data set and double check or triple
check each other and you can get like 95
label accuracy
but you pay three times as much so this
is not very feasible for most people to
do right
another example is how do i understand
what are the types of things that my
model sucks on so i can get more data of
that well the way that you know you do
this is you know there's a famous story
of you know andre carpathi just like
spending like two three hours every day
just like looking through every single
example in this data set one by one and
building some mental attention mental
clustering of what the failure cases are
but you know that doesn't scale right
that's also just kind of a waste of
talent i think but
so you want to do this in a more
efficient way you want to find here are
these like needles in the haystack
and you want to be able to search
through your large data set to be able
to get them efficiently
and so what you want to do is you want
to set up essentially a feedback loop
you want to be able to set up a way that
you discover these in an efficient way
and so one thing that you can do that is
more domain specific is have a way to
double check
what is going on in your data or in your
model and so one thing you can do is you
can have humans go and actually double
check some sample of the predictions
that your model outputs and you know
this is basically domain specific
because sometimes your model runs once a
day that's easy to check other times it
runs 10 times a second that's hard to
check
so
uh and then you can also do things where
you can check you know disagreements or
agreements between different systems
like ensembles or you know heuristic
versus learn systems whatever right
but the other thing you can do is you
can actually ask the model
where it thinks things are hard and have
the model essentially automate the
process of searching through your data
to tell you where the problems in the
data are which is like kind of a weird
unintuitive concept but you know i can
explain that a little bit more
so there's a few different things you
can do you can try to like know surface
labeling errors automatically by
checking the places where the model and
the data disagree
you can find error patterns in the model
by essentially asking it what it thinks
is similar or dissimilar in the data set
or you can understand the difference in
distribution between what you are seeing
in your training environment versus what
you see in production
so
this is an example of a self-driving
data set where you do object detection
draw a box around a car or a pedestrian
or whatever and it turns out you know
the dumb way of course of finding
labeling errors is you just manually
check everything
but what you can do is you can ask the
model here are the things that the model
is very confident about where it
disagrees with the human annotations the
labels
and it turns out it bubbles up all these
places where the model was right and the
humans were wrong so instead of you know
looking through all million data points
to find the problems you find sort of
the thousand things that bubble up to
the top
saves you a lot of time but you still
have a human to like double check yeah
this is right this is wrong but that
human is an expert and now they're
looking through like a thousand things
instead of a million things
so those dash lines are all like you
know boxes around cars that are
correctly there but uh we're not labeled
in
you know a similar thing can happen not
only in you know let's say images but
also in different types of sensor
modality because you know deep learning
basically allows you to run on different
types of like
sensors
and still get like similar results so in
this case you have a 3d object detection
task where you have like a 3d point
cloud from a lidar sensor a 3d sensor
and your task is to draw a box around it
and sometimes the model will detect
things that are just not labeled by the
annotators
and look you know like there's actually
a person that's just kind of like hidden
there in the distance and the model
correctly detects it with high
confidence but it just wasn't labeled in
you know even though the guy next to him
was labeled in so now you found a
labeling error
another problem you have is like okay
well like you know in these sort of like
deep learning scenarios you have a lot
of patterns of edge cases and it follows
kind of this tail distribution where
like your model tends to do very well on
the common case then you have these sort
of rarer and rarer edge cases and then
suddenly the model doesn't do so well
because it hasn't seen many examples
so you need to be able to identify okay
what are the things in my long tail that
my model struggles on and then how do i
get more data of them
so one thing you can do
is you can use something called a neural
network embedding and this is something
that's well known from the language
processing field but essentially what
you can do is you can ask a neural
network to tell you what it thinks is
similar it's similar in a data set so if
you have a bunch of images or a bunch of
audio clips or a bunch of point clouds
you can say okay well here's a bunch of
stuff that i think is similar to each
other and here's a bunch of stuff i
think is like an outlier and you can
represent it in this nice visualization
that allows you to kind of understand
here's the layout of the distribution
of my data set so in this case you have
a bunch of images of you know
shibuyinus and you can see that the vast
majority of shibuyas are in this cluster
in the middle because they're all like
orange coats
but if you look at some of the outliers
you see that you know there's shibuyas
that have white coats
and then what you can do is you can then
understand okay well if my model fails
on particular sort of subsets of the
data
then you know that's something where i
may want to understand that this is a
cluster of stuff that my model
consistently disagrees with the label on
and therefore that's an edge case
and then also if i know that this is
something where the model consistently
fails on it i want to go and collect
more data and label that and retrain my
model on that what we can actually do is
then say okay let's use these embeddings
to search through my unlabeled data like
you know a search engine
and then use that to do essentially
targeted data collections instead of you
having to mainly dig through it
uh so yeah that's the 90
here's a 10 show we build tools that
make all this stuff easier
so you know we have a vested interest in
uh this problem being big but you know
to be honest like this is kind of the
tool that i wanted when i was at cruz
and
i wish we had it so this is kind of the
thing that i feel like has just been
really useful for doing sort of normal
deep learning tasks where you have an
incentive to make something better in
production you want to do it faster you
want to ship better models and we're
building tools that kind of makes that
happen so
let's see i think we might be out of
time
all right well i'll be in office hours
[Applause]